recently I happen to be sitting next to
Hugh Jackman at this Wow all right here
we go
so wow I didn't know that what other
awkward thing I could talk about but to
be like am I gonna see you soon I don't
know and but he said a couple of things
to me and I'll just I'll just leave it
at that because I feel like otherwise
I'm gonna get into trouble with somebody
but no you just so think about that no
but but yeah you know I asked him cuz I
kept thinking I was like he said whether
or not that was Logan was supposed to be
the last
Wolverine thing or whatever and and it's
you know he said to me what he's I think
he publicly said out there which was
like he's been thinking about it and he
you know it's on his mind so I don't
know you maybe I think Sebastian I think
phones off please please are can you
rewind the last 15 seconds Twitter just
broke way to go awesome well let's keep
that going so Justice League how about
you guys fight the Justice League maybe
we could do who is that
yeah exactly
oh we won the last 35 seconds record
over that hey everybody it's Charlie
I've gotten a lot of questions about
this Hugh Jackman Wolverine rumour in
Avengers end game like people
legitimately think that he's in the
movie and I think it's kind of
ridiculous but I'll try to explain
what's going on where the rumor came
from in the evidence like the crazier
people are pointing to thinking that
it's actual evidence but hopefully for
most of you common sense will prevail
I know Sebastian San was trying to start
a little bit of a Hugh Jackman fire last
year when he did this they did that
comic-con panel in the lead up to
infinity war I did a video on this
earlier this year just because it's very
provocative like I say I'm just having a
little bit of fun with the audience so
it is fun to listen to them [ __ ]
with each other like that because they
can't actually give away real spoilers
for the movie because even though they
joke about Marvel snipers in the
background waiting to pick them up they
really are people at Marvel that are
dedicated to keeping actors from
spoiling stuff we are doing a new round
of that imax ticket giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave your favorite Marvel rumor on
the video even if you think that it's a
fake rumor just leave your favorite
rumor on the video so what's happened is
is in the past couple of weeks you may
see websites reporting the Hugh Jackman
is supposed to be an Avengers end game
the minute I heard that I immediately
discounted it is completely false just
because it sounds ridiculous like he
wasn't even in Deadpool - why would he
be an Avengers end game if he wasn't
gonna be in Ryan Reynolds movie if
they're like brothers have you seen
their Instagram feeds like they spent
all of this past year promoting each
other's movie with funny Instagram
stories Ryan Reynolds may singing like
an honest hard-working movie star
husband and father but don't let the
fact get
way of the truth the truth he's been
riding Hugh Jackman's coattails since
2009 when Hugh hands selected him to
star an x-men origins Wolverine in the
universally acclaimed the best portrayal
of Wade Wilson ever the truth
Ryan was only named People magazine's
sexiest man alive in 2010 the year after
he met Hugh coincidence please the truth
you can soon see Ryan in once upon a
Deadpool and support the fudge cancer
charity at the same time please do it or
he might make another Van Wilder movie
or worse yet green lanten that Oh
Sherman and I approve this message from
Hugh Jackman's upcoming performance in
the frontrunner has fooled some people
into thinking he deserves an award but
before voting begins some people should
consider these facts Hugh Jackman isn't
his real name it's Hugh Michael Jackman
Hugh Michael speaks with a charming
accent but he's actually from Milwaukee
he then walked off the job on Wolverine
adding to unemployment is this the type
of amazing actor a nice person we want
delivering a preachy liberal speech this
award season or maybe there's a real
foreigner from a bordering country who
would really love it a lot
think before you vote but definitely see
the front-runner the real reason he
didn't have a cameo during Deadpool 2 is
because he was busy promoting his other
films that he had just done previously
in Ryan Reynolds put that Wolverine
Origins clip at the end anyway so that
was kind of a Hugh Jackman cameo but the
crazier people that were thinking that
Hugh Jackman is actually going to appear
in Avengers endgame we're using this
strange Google search as evidence so
what happens is if you go into Google
and you search for this very specific
term famous Hugh Jackman movies you get
like a little pop-up that shows Avengers
endgame so people just assume oh wow
well Avengers endgame is appearing near
his movie that must mean that he's in it
any other search terms you use Hugh
Jackman movies or Hugh Jackman movie you
can't get that to reappear so very
clearly it's an aberration it's just
some weird error that Google searches
returning there were people a little
while ago that we're trying to claim
that the IMDB was listing Hugh Jackman
IMDB like Wikipedia are all so thin
that can be edited by anybody that can
type a keyboard so IMDB is like the
worst possible place you could go to
find evidence of something actually
happening in a movie you may have seen
the Kevin Feige video that I posted a
little while ago with him talking about
his x-men plans for this year in the
timeline of the Fox Disney deal now
Kevin Feige has given very conservative
estimates for when that would be
completed but obviously once they get
their x-men characters they can put any
character they want in a movie but even
if he did want to put Wolverine Hugh
Jackman in a movie Hugh Jackman himself
would have to agree to that and if he
wasn't ready to shoot new Wolverine
footage with his BFF Ryan Reynolds for
Deadpool - or even when they did the
reshoot for once upon a Deadpool the
pg-13 cut with all the Fred Savage stuff
then he's probably not going to appear
during x-men Dark Phoenix and he's
probably not going to appear during
Avengers endgame the main goal of
Avengers endgame / what the Russos and
Kevin Feige have said is mainly to
change the Marvel Cinematic Universe in
a really fundamental way because of the
plot of how they actually fixed the
universe and get all those snapped
people back from the dead but also to
close the book on the first era of
characters and stories from phase 1 and
give you a sense for what's to come more
from some of those characters that stick
around and give you a direction for some
of the newer characters that we know are
coming back like spider-man and black
panther the language that Kevin Feige
used was telling stories with characters
you already know like Black Widow but in
unexpected ways like doing a Black Widow
movie but set during the past before the
events of the first Avengers movie
Avengers endgame is not meant to
shoehorn in all those new x-men
characters like they're not gonna have
Professor X like we allowed and give
everybody a thumbs up just because they
can't because supposedly now the Disney
Fox deal will be done by the end of
January so all that really means is is
that Kevin Feige will be able to pay
writers and producers to develop ideas
that they can then turn into projects
based on the stuff that he already has
in his head like in the interviews that
he's done in the past year he has talked
about x-men like oh I have a lot of
ideas but the lawyers at Disney tell me
that I can't do anything about that
until the deal is done all I would
expect from avengers endgame is that the
approaches leave room for plausible
theory crafting like oh you know based
on these plot points like for instance
the quantum realm and the way the
quantum energy has fundamentally changed
Janet Van Dyne that could be a precursor
to mute
in the MCU there was even a guidebook
the sort of canonized Scarlet Witch is a
proto mutant in the MCU version of this
universe right now pre x-men like saying
that the mind gem didn't give her powers
it just unlocked latent abilities
already within her which is basically
saying that the mine stone unlocked her
X gene without actually using the words
X gene or mutant for copyright reasons
because when the book was made they
obviously didn't have any of that Fox IP
yet I made a couple videos about the
Eternals movie franchise the Kevin Feige
teased and how it's going to fit into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe before the
Fox Disney deal it actually started to
happen they were meant to be sort of the
in-between precursor to actually
biologically based powers in the MCU
like a way to explain how you have
mutants without actually calling them
mutants but now that they're actually
getting all those Fox characters you
don't need to do any kind of work around
you can go straight to X gene mutant
people can have biological powers and
start popping up all over the world in
the wake of what happens at the end of
Avengers endgame but even though the CEO
of Disney Bob Iger and Kevin Feige both
been hyping up x-men inside the MCU in
the future neither one of them is going
to be a super big dick to all those Fox
x-men actors that are getting ready to
release Dark Phoenix June 7th after
avengers endgame and after the Fox
Disney deal closes like I wouldn't
expect to hear anything about official
x-men plans until we get to comic-con
later this summer at the end of July and
if you're really bummed out at the
thought that Hugh Jackman might never
play The Wolverine character again be it
in a Deadpool cameo or in an MCU movie
all I have to say right now is Secret
Wars most plausible theory for bringing
back some of those legacy actors and
really cool cameos is in say like
Avengers 6 in like 6 to 7 years if they
do a secret war style movie with a bunch
of multiverse characters so just
remember it's the comic book universe
anything is possible as long as there's
a really cool twist and some cool story
behind it and Kevin Feige is a master of
doing things like that so I'm sure he
has a plan to make this all fit together
in a really cool way that we'll probably
find out about later this year but let
me know in the comments if Marvel waits
a couple years to recast the Wolverine
character and Hugh Jackman does want to
come back how do you want them to use
that character inside an MCU movie click
here to listen to that full Avengers and
game vid
where kevin feige talks about his x-men
plans in his history marvel and click
here to learn how Marvel just retconned
Thor and Loki 's character before
Avengers endgame thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]